do you even realize how much you've done
for foster kids who look at you and say
do you mean she was once where I am
Tiffany Haddish fights back tears
realizing the significance of her impact
so just filled my heart up because I
remember being that kid gonna like oh
I'll never be anything you know I'll
just I'm gonna be a baby mama like you
know get some child support checks or
something like that that probably be the
best I could do and now that I know like
you really can do anything you put your
mind to the 38 year old was recognized
at essence magazines black women in
Hollywood alongside Hollywood
powerhouses Danai gurira
Tessa Thompson and Lena wait in honor
that was not lost on her what does it
mean to you than to be in this room
today with these women supporting you
lifting you up and celebrating you
it means the world to me it's the most
amazing feeling in the world
meanwhile fellow comedian Lonnie love
tells et she couldn't agree more I grew
up with Tiffany in the comedy game to
see you know her being honored as long
as well as the other women this is the
reason why we have this every year the
girls trip star has literally taken the
world by storm
the Oprah thing happened like Ellen now
you host MTV Awards I mean everything
but there's still one thing missing I
haven't gone on a date with Michael B
Jordan yet you know he was supposed to
be here today but he's not coming now
that's okay that's okay it'll have you
been fishing I think he's getting the
picture I'm pretty sure he did I'm
pretty sure he's getting the picture but
it's okay if that don't happen but you
know also I want you know I want to own
two streets that intersect called
Tiffany Haddish
I'm building an empire
[Music]